[Applaudissements]
retour au confinement total pour la
bande de gaza c'est en tout cas ce que
préconise dans un communiqué le
ministère de la santé du hamas
face à l'augmentation des cas de kobe de
19 sur le territoire une déclarations
alarmantes qui s'appuie sur les
conclusions de l'organisation mondiale
de la santé selon lagence dans ces
conditions et face à l'épuisement des
ressources
la bande de gaza ne pourra pas résisté
plus de deux semaines supplémentaires
l'augmentation continue du nombre de
personnes infectées par le recours aux
navires us dans la bande de gaza reste
un facteur alarmant et aléatoires ce qui
nous avertit que la situation peut
s'aggraver dans les prochains jours
surtout compte tenu du début de la
saison hivernale au cours de laquelle
les virus se multiplient et deviennent
plus actifs
cela oblige les citoyens à respecter
encore plus strictement les mesures de
précaution afin que nous puissions
stabiliser et contrôler le taux
d'infection chambre des mesures de
précaution qui semble essentiel dans une
enclave où les autorités n'ont pas
imposer de restrictions de déplacements
les soignants tire la sonnette d'alarmé
au sujet du manque de matériel
la bande de gaza compte 150 lits en
soins intensifs pour plus de 100
patients en état critique
une situation qui oblige le corps
médical à s'adapter en reportant
certaines opérations jugées non
essentielles selon le jerusalem post le
hamas au pouvoir à gaza accuse israël
d'avoir bloqué l'approvisionnement en
équipements médicaux la propagation de
l'épidémie et l'augmentation des cas de
maladie ont pris des dimensions
alarmantes dans la bande de gaza je
pense que la situation est devenue
dangereuse et nous pouvons en perdre le
contrôle
cela fait incomber la responsabilité de
ce qui se passe à ceux qui ont orchestré
ce blocus et en particulier sur les
occupants israéliens
je pense que les groupes palestiniens
veulent aujourd'hui transmettre un
message clair est ouvert pas secret ou
privés un message absolument
compréhensible et ne laissant place à
aucune ambiguïté un message selon lequel
ce sont les occupants israéliens qui
sont responsables du blocus de la bande
de gaza les occupants israéliens sont
obligés de livrer des équipements
spéciaux dans le secteur de gaza pour
lutter contre l'épidémie de coronavirus
un confinement total pourrait donc se
mettre en place pour tenter de ralentir
le virus une solution que cherche
pourtant à éviter la population alors
que le taux de chômage est
particulièrement élevé dans la bande de
gaza une
elle mise sous cloche pourrait porter un
coup fatal à l'économie de l'enclavé
[Musique]